These cuts are blood money.
People will die.
Let's be very clear:
Senate Republicans are paying for tax cuts
for the wealthy with American lives.
People need kidneys.
It's sad but decreed.
Yet this Senator's hoarding one more than
she needs.
I offer this bill and I hope you'll vote aye
unless of course you just want people to die.
Traffic deaths have many crying with fear.
Over thirty thousand people are dying each
year.
This modest change I propose must be applied
unless of course you just want people to die.
Alcohol deaths are exceeding comparisons,
black people, white people, native American.
We need to ban alcohol, it can't be denied,
unless of course you just want people to die.
Murders are bad, they have no defenders.
Yet many are committed by repeat offenders.
I say lifetime in prison whatever the crime,
unless of course you just want people to die.
I don't have a bill, or a groan to detail,
I just need a short clip for my donor email.
Tim there's blood on your hands!
You want people to die!
That good? Cool.
Tim, dinner at five?
Yeah.
The car deaths I mentioned are terrible stuff.
Doesn't seem one seat-belt is ever enough.
You must vote for my act so that fewer will
cry,
unless of course you just want people to die.
The carbs, the container, we cannot ignore
whipped cream's killing more people than ever
before.
This bill would be passed and be ratified
if those people that didn't want people to
die.
Why not weigh all the costs?
the effects, the results.
Empathize with each other as if we were adults.
Use our brains to craft arguments not vilify.
See that freedom's a trade-off.
You want
people to die!
I tried.